there was one main subject on the agenda
at miracles last news conference before
her summer break us surveillance
operations in Germany the Chancellor
faced a barrage of questions from
journalists about us intelligence
activities in the country Zuma now a
constitutional state all of our security
efforts serve just one goal and that is
to protect the individual dodgeville
Germany is not a surveillance state
Germany is a land of freedom I lunt def
hide miracle sought to counter
accusations her government had not done
enough to confront the US / prism the
secret program gathering the private
data of Germany citizens among others
would Chancellor Merkel investigate how
prism works he's mine it's not up to me
to familiarize myself with the details
of prism at a certain point in time I
got a different job
with questions about us surveillance
seemingly exhausted attention then
turned to Germany's upcoming general
elections miracle CDU party still leads
in the polls but with the vote expected
to be tight she's got a busy couple of
months ahead in terms of recuperating
the safest thing to do as Chancellor's
to be able to recover while doing the
job would that something America will
have to do for a few more days after
that she'll be taking a proper vacation